Walter, you're up late.
>> I find my mind is most clear when
the moon is in the eleventh house.
>> Mm.
Wait, what?
>> So life update.
I decided that I wanted to
upscale it my current career.
So I signed up for Udacity's fortune
teller and future seer nanodegree.
>> Mm, interesting.
Man, I wish that there was some way
that I could see into the future of
ShoppingList++.
With things so up in the air
with the data structure, man,
a little foresight would
be really helpful.
>> Here,
why don't you just take this amulet?
It'll light up prophetic
visions of the future beyond.
Just say what you want to see three
times before you go to sleep.
>> Walter, this is amazing.
Can I keep this?
>> Yeah, sure.
I'm on to bigger and better things now.
Now I'm going to go turn
Palter into a frog.
>> Yeah, a frog.